Silence from the royals over Harry's
Memoirs not so the Taliban with
officials from the militant group
appearing on camera the prince's wartime
admissions providing them with a
propaganda platform
s
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in his book called spare amongst the
Royal Revelations the king's second son
said he'd killed 25 Taliban fighters
during two tours of Duty prompting
criticism he might be putting people at
risk at events such as his own
forthcoming Invictus games for injured
service personnel
the former head of the Navy Admiral Lord
West called Harry's admission very
stupid writing in the Sunday Mirror he
said the Invictus games is very much
labeled to him and so I would have
thought the Threat Level there will
definitely be higher there will be
serious security issues because of what
he said measures will have to be put in
place to protect the veterans
and what of other events linked to
Prince Harry we don't yet know if he'll
attend the king's coronation I certainly
have to be a reassessment of the
security profile and protection around
Harry given those comments and what
might come out of the chat rooms of
jihadist movements so in that sense Lord
West is absolutely correct but a veteran
who took part in the Invictus games in
Orlando in America in 2016 told Sky News
he believes the threat risk is being
over hyped you're talking about a global
event where a vvip is attending so if
you think that the security risk isn't
heightened anyway then that's a it's a
crazy thing to say and the people that
have that are speaking out about him
are very hypocritical because there are
dozens and dozens of military books that
people are writing that it tells the
number that they have killed Prince
Harry will surely have anticipated an
unhappy response to his Memoirs from the
Royals in the event he's now fighting
fires on another front with the Taliban
Lisa Holland Sky News